hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Bobby who is an
author just wrote a novel whisper has a
website and what at my advice on how to
get that book up at going and selling so
let's check out the site to start so it
looks like it's just a landing page at
the moment let's turn off the music here
this is just a landing page nothing so
just a contact in a home page so for
here I don't really know what your book
is about so I see a street setting here
it might be good idea to say a little
bit about what your book is about a lot
of times on these landing pages you want
to leave a box or people to be able to
put their name and information in so you
can email them when something comes out
or if you want to have people pre-order
the book it's a great way so whoever is
in the site it may not be a lot of
people yet but you can get people to
potentially pre-order at least sign up
for a newsletter to know when it's
coming out so that's usually kind of
standard for these types of launches so
this doesn't really tell me anything so
again I want to know a little bit about
what the book is about give me an option
to sign up for more information when it
comes out or potentially even pre-order
I also try to show some testimonials on
here so who has read the book who really
loves it show a picture show some quotes
help build up the hype right so book
coming soon isn't going to do too much
to build up the hype you want to
actually show people getting excited it
could be a video of them saying how
great it is or just them you know I have
a written text of what they've done what
they've read in how they like it from
there you know once you launch it it's
the challenge of getting the word out
and you can go two ways one is through
the mainstream media again I have noted
what the book is about but if it's
hitting on any kind of hot topic then
you can approach media as an expert and
you can get the book showcase and you
know your subject matter experts you can
be featured you could build your own PR
list or you can use a service like PR
leads that I've used in the past to get
into the media and see what they're
talking about and get featured i found
that print tends to work the best in
terms of getting people to go to a
website because it's written down they
can copy and paste and put it into the
browser and go over to your site but you
know when you're first getting this
thing launched you're really to go ready
to go to whoever wants to cover you so
that's one way is mainstream the other
way i'd go is try to get the online
media so look at bloggers who cover
books and who cover the area that you're
talking about so if whisper has elements
of personal development you can go you
know talk two persons relevant blogs if
its elements of travel you could talk to
travel blogs basically you want to get
the people who are interested in this
type of book to talk about it and you
can give them review copies you can
potentially write a guest blog on their
blog to talk about the book you can give
them as prizes to their readers you
basically want to kick up some attention
so that there you are willing to you
know promote you a little bit and get
the word out about your blog sorry your
book so hopefully that's a good start
once people visit the site again you
want to get their information you might
want to have a blog here as well to show
you know more content and preview other
things that you're working on but
definitely a little bit more than what
you've got here right now it's a great
start it looks nice looks professional
but I try to add a little bit more on
there and start building up some more
momentum to help drive some interest in
the book so hopefully that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below and it also love to hear
your comments if you want to leave one
end of the video and stay tuned for next
episode
I
you